When it comes to modern-day action stars,
a few names always have to enter the mix.
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson follows in the long,
storied tradition of larger-than-life figures.
Honestly, anyone who's been in a "Fast &
Furious" movie falls into that category,
and that goes double with one of the hardest
working men in Hollywood — Jason Statham.
Throughout the 21st century, he's starred
in some of the most critically-acclaimed
heist and action flicks, such as "The Italian
Job," "Crank," and "War." When you walk into a
Statham movie, you know exactly what you're
getting, but not every film can be a hit.
Others fall off the radar, but older
movies have managed to find a second life
thanks to the glut of streaming services as
of late. That's the case for the underrated
Statham movie "Chaos," which
is now making waves on Netflix.
The movie only grossed $7 million globally during
its run, but now's your chance of seeing what you
missed 16 years ago. See why the film has
broken into the platform's Top 10 Movies,
especially if you're a fan
of Statham's other works.
Statham plays a veteran detective named Quentin
Conners who is reprimanded and then quickly
reinstated onto the force when a group of
criminals takes hostages in a bank. He's
teamed up with rookie cop Shane Dekker, and things
take a turn for the worse when they discover the
thieves uploaded a computer virus into the
bank's systems capable of random evolution.
The virus follows the principles of chaos
theory, which is where the film gets its name,
so it's a race against the clock for the
officers to figure out a way to stop the attack.
You'd be forgiven for missing the film
when it first came out. It didn't receive
a theatrical release in the United States,
going straight-to-video instead. That's a
bit of a surprise, considering that Statham's
star was on the rise in the early 2000s thanks
to his appearance in movies like "The Transporter"
series and "The Italian Job." And that's not even
to mention the fact that Ryan Phillippe and Wesley
Snipes, themselves well-known actors at the time,
co-star in the movie. The few critics that
did review "Chaos" were mostly underwhelmed,
but that only paints half a picture in regard to
how the film has been received over the years.
Reel Film gave the movie two stars
out of five and complained that the
movie's occasional moments of strong
action filmmaking were otherwise,
"Bogged down with an overwrought and
overplayed sensibility that proves disastrous."
The outlet said the movie lacked
originality and concluded,
"The equally impressive performances
ensure that boredom never entirely sets in,
though it's awfully difficult to look past the
almost laughably inept instances of
plotting within Giglio's screenplay."
The film did have its defenders, though. Fernby
Films enjoyed Statham's performance and noted
"it's got some delightfully done set-pieces
..." They concluded their review by writing,
"While I wasn't expecting a whole lot,
what I got was thoroughly enjoyable and
most definitely a film worth watching."
So, all in all, a pretty mixed-to-negative
response from critics. When it comes to
audience reactions though, movie-goers
seemed to enjoy the Statham action flick.
With a movie like "Chaos," critical reception
should be taken with a grain of salt.
After all, not everyone is tuning into a
Statham headliner for strong characters
and an intricate plot. And for
movie fans who left reviews on IMDB,
the consensus seems to be that
"Chaos" is, all in all, a fun watch.
One user said,
"All the signs were pointing to this
being a bad movie. It is fun to watch
and the film does present [an] intriguing mystery
with a few surprising twists along the way."
Another user also had a fun time
with "Chaos" despite their nitpicks.
They loved the movie's "twists and turns"
and while they did take issue with some
of the character choices, they ultimately said,
"But for a popcorn thriller,
this was quite entertaining. Any film with
Statham in it is always worth a watch."
With the movie currently killing it
on Netflix, it looks like audiences
are in agreement that "Chaos" is one
forgotten gem that's worth checking out.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.